-Our guest tonight is a Grammy
Award-winning singer/songwriter,
whose third album "Solar Power
is out on August 20th.
Please, welcome back to
the show, our friend, Lorde.
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Hello. So nice to see you.
Welcome back.
[ Applause ]
This is --
This is very lovely for me
because I also
saw you last week,
and I feel like we had
the benefit of getting to
catch up over some alcohol
-We did more than just catch up.
-Yeah.
-I feel like we really close
the gap really fast.
-I think we closed the gap
pretty --
We took advantage of your --
you're a very scheduled person
as you were doing an album
launch and we only had a coupl
hours to drink a lot of drinks
-We got so blasted.
Like, I -- I don't know
if you realize
how drunk you're really gettin
when you do this thing.
-I think it was very nice yo
pointed out to me early,
you are not someone who
necessarily shows right away
You have a reputation
amongst your friends.
-Very poised. Very poised drunk.
You'd ever know the difference
-That's what everyone says
about me.
[ Laughter ]
-But I'm scared.
I'm scared to see this thing
-That's right.
You haven't seen it yet.
I'm very excited.
Congratulations on the album
-Thank you.
-This is very exciting.
And I want to talk about
some of the places you wer
while you were working
on this album.
One which made sense,
you went home.
You were in New Zealand.
How is it transitioning back
to a place like New York City?
Which obviously is a wonderful
place to be,
but New Zealand, very differen
than New York City.
-Very different.
I would say, the main thin
I observed between
the difference between
New Zealand and America
apart from the obvious sort of
COVID protocols and such..
every food at the grocery
store is --
It's a hotdog, but it's almonds.
It's a sundae, but it's almonds.
Like, it's cream cheese,
but it's almonds.
Like, everything
is made of a nut.
Do you --
Do you know what I mean?
-We are very proud of that
You haven't brought --
you haven't brought nuts into --
-We have maybe a nut milk.
But the, you know, full sundae
-Oh, yeah.
The almonds have taken over.
-You know, the ice cream.
The -- The almonds
have taken over.
That is the main thing.
-I think if you asked anyone
what the difference is between
New York and New Zealand,
you are the only one
who had that answer.
-The nuts, yeah.
-You also went to Antarctica
-I did.
-Now, is that something
you'd always wanted to do?
-Always, since I was a kid
I was a total history buff
Completely obsessed.
I'd always wanted to go,
and I got the chance to do it.
It's really difficult
to get there.
You have to get a million shots.
-Okay.
-There has to be like nothin
physically wrong with you
because there's not much kind of
medical stuff down there.
It's a whole process,
but it was amazing.
It was like a pilgrimage,
you know?
-I think it's safe to say
it's freezing, freezing cold
-It's so cold.
-Okay.
-So cold. And it's like
the height of summer.
You know?
It's as warm as it gets.
-But it's also --
This obviously also makes sense,
but I felt dumb not realizing it
until I read it.
It's incredibly sunny.
-It's sunny all day.
The sun does not go down.
Yeah.
It's -- It messes
with your head.
-Because I think when you see an
album called "Solar Power,
you start thinking about, "Oh,
you wrote it on the beach.
And obviously you spend a fair
amount of time on the beach,
but you are also --
a little bit of the inspiratio
came from Antarctica.
-Yeah.
I just, like, I -- you know, the
album is very much about nature,
and to go there and experience
nature in this very raw form
was really inspiring for me.
-Last time you were here,
which was way back,
was right
before your second album.
And we talked a little bit about
when you have
an incredibly
popular debut album.
You have to follow it up
with a sophomore album
which, again, was very popular
Do you feel less pressure
going to a third album?
Or as an artist, is it jus
going to be each time out?
-I think last time
I was so nervous.
I think everyone's nervous
before their second album.
But it went quite well.
And I think I sort of could have
done anything I wanted.
And this one, I felt like
I just made for my peers
to, like, amuse other musicians.
Or, you know,
I was like let's just flex
and do something that will
make this musician text me
going like,
"I see what you did there.
-That's really nice.
I think that is a good way
of going about it.
You also worked with
Jack Antonoff again.
-I did.
-This is someone who
I imagine you have a very
intensely close relationship
even though a lot
of it was happening over Zoom?
-Yeah, we managed to not write
any songs on Zoom,
which was great.
Because I was dreading
that part of it.
We FaceTimed a lot.
And just sort of like waited
till we could be together again.
You know, he and I have know
each other for years
and we knew it would happe
eventually, but it was weird
We just sort of like locked down
in the studio in New York.
No one else could
come into the room
and we had the windows open,
doors open, the whole time
So you can kind of hear like
sirens of the West Village
You know, it's very --
-That's fantastic.
Um, first of all, I want to sa
thank you so much.
I am so glad
you are doing a song.
This is really
a hat trick of Lorde
because we got to talk to you,
we are going to get music
from you,
and when we come back,
we are going to watch
"Day Drinking" together,
so do not go anywhere.
Stick around.